what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and recently we've
gotten quite a bit of new footage for
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and it looks like the main plot
of the movie at least a very important
part of the movie has been revealed
within all of this new footage that
we've gotten over the past week from
everything that we've heard so far
multiverse of madness is going to be a
pretty ground breaking film at least in
the marvel cinematic universe benedict
cumberbatch has said that he believes
this movie is going to be bigger than
spider-man knowing home now he's not
talking box office numbers he's just
talking about everything that's going to
be happening and taking place within
this movie and we all know it's going to
be huge but the new footage that we've
gotten this week put some emphasis on
wanda and the illuminati now we know
wanda is going to fight members of the
illuminati and she's going to basically
attack them at their headquarters but
the big question is why what exactly is
she doing i believe we have figured out
that answer and that's exactly what
we're going to be talking about in this
video today now i'm sure if you're
watching this video you saw the trailer
that marvel studios released this week
titled marvel studios is doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness dream this
trailer was pretty epic because in the
first trailer that we got for multiverse
of madness the first official trailer
not the teaser we heard dr strange say
every night he's been dreaming the same
dream and then the nightmare begins but
in this trailer it starts off with
doctor strange saying that but then
wanda takes over and her line is
basically the same she says every night
the same dream but every morning the
same nightmare now when they show this
part where she says dream she sees her
two kids billy and tommy the kids that
she magically created in one division
but when she says nightmare the kids are
taken away much like they were in one
division and of course it's important to
know that in the post-credits scene for
one division while wanda is studying the
darkhold as the scarlet witch she hears
the voices of her two kids enter the
main plot for this movie and why wanda
is going to be attacking the illuminati
now it's not actually what you think
wanda doesn't really initially have beef
with the illuminati but i'll explain why
in just a bit this trailer emphasized
that the focus of wanda in this movie is
going to be to get her kids back she's
going to do whatever it takes to try and
find her children because she believes
that they are really out there perhaps
in another universe and wanda's been
through a lot of pain there's nothing
wrong with her wanting to find her kids
obviously but there is a problem wanda
is learning about the multiverse and
learning about dark magic from the dark
hold and the dark hold was created by
the ancient elder god c'thun and in the
comics c'thun is actually responsible
for giving wanda her chaos magic before
he was banished from earth's realm he
actually touched wanda when she was a
baby and he sort of imprinted chaos
magic onto her now the reason he did
this was because he hoped one day
eventually he would use her as a vessel
to return to earth now i'm not sure if
c'thun is really behind everything going
on in multiverse madness but i do know
that the darkhold is kind of going to
corrupt wanda this is what's going to
really set her off and sort of go on a
killing spree and unfortunately that
means that she's going to probably be
killing many members of the illuminati
and probably other cameos as well now
i'm kind of all for this i think it's
going to be really cool i just don't
want her to kill professor x again we've
already seen that enough i don't want to
go through it again but killing other
people who randomly pop up as cameos
from other universes yeah sure why not
really show us that you are truly the
most powerful being in the multiverse
this is a lesson that the illuminati is
going to learn and unfortunately it's
kind of not their fault you see i do
believe wanda has vast knowledge of the
multiverse but i actually think that
she's going to have a hard time
traveling to different universes which
means that she's going to be looking for
a way to be able to jump two different
universes to find her kids and this is
where the trouble for the illuminati
actually starts and it's all about
america chavez played by the wonderful
sochi gomez and in this new trailer they
actually show us the scene where the
trouble begins at the illuminati's
headquarters you see america chavez has
the ability to create portals in the
multiverse portals that can take you to
another universe she can kick open
star-shaped holes in reality in the
comics she also has superhuman strength
and speed and can fly but we'll see
about that in the movie but we do know
her power is definitely going to be
opening portals to other universes which
is why the scarlet witch is going to be
hunting her down i actually believe this
is why america chavez is going to end up
in our universe i don't think she's
actually from our universe to begin with
in the comics she is actually born and
raised in the utopian parallel which is
a reality that is outside of time and is
in the presence of a being known as the
demiurge who she claims gave her her
powers now i believe the scenes that
we've seen in some of the trailers where
dr strange is in the street protecting
america chavez from gargantos is
actually when she first shows up to our
universe from there the scarlet witch is
going to do everything she can to get
her so she can use her to open up
portals for her to go and look for her
kids this is where the fun begins
because while she's doing this doctor
strange is actually going to be charged
by the illuminati for threatening the
multiverse as we've heard master mordo
say in the trailers the biggest threat
to the multiverse is you steven strange
so we've seen stephen and we've seen
america chavez both be captured by the
illuminati put in handcuffs and put in
prison cells in fact one of the opening
scenes of the new trailer is doctor
strange laying on the floor of the
prison cell in handcuffs now thanks to
the first full official trailer we know
that from here doctor strange is going
to be taken to the court of the
illuminati where they're going to judge
him basically put him on trial but we
know that the scarlet witch shows up and
she begins to fight with some of the
members of the illuminati we know thanks
to some statues that have been seen in
certain scenes that she does indeed go
to the headquarters of the illuminati
and she does indeed kind of destroy it
but why is she there she's there for
america chavez america chavez is being
kept in a prison cell by the illuminati
at their headquarters which brings the
scarlet witch there so this is what's
gonna happen she's gonna show up demand
that america chavez be given to her and
the illuminati is gonna say no and
they'll probably be pretty cocky stating
that they are the most powerful beings
in the universe they watch over the
multiverse and that she can't really
take them all on but unfortunately she
can and she's definitely going to and
this is where a new scene in the new
trailer comes into play we see a scene
with christine palmer in the prison area
where america chavez is still in her
prison cell then behind her we can see
that clearly chaos is going around there
are people running around everywhere
christine and america chavez look really
shocked and the ultron bots are running
towards something this has to be when
the scarlet witch attacks the illuminati
because as you can see doctor strange is
not in that other prison cell which
means he is in the court of the
illuminati at the time we've also seen
mordo take out a sword and attack doctor
strange this is going to be at the same
time as well because i'm assuming that
the illuminati might assume that doctor
strange and wanda are still working
together so they're gonna view him as a
threat as well especially since his
recent actions have threatened the
entire multiverse now from here i don't
think it's good news for almost anybody
in the illuminati maybe mordo survives
maybe not and i will add that i do think
he is a variant of mordo since all the
toy figurines state that he is master
mordo so i think that he's the sorceress
supreme of whatever universe that he
comes from but from here wanda is going
to fight the maria rambo variant of
captain marvel and although it does look
like a really cool battle i don't doubt
that the scarlet witch will kill her and
i think the same goes for the rest of
the illuminati unfortunately including
professor x again i hope we don't see
him die but he's probably gonna try and
get in wanda's head and it's probably
not gonna be too good for him and from
here i think wanda is going to turn into
the real true villain of the movie the
illuminati will be an important part but
they're not the villains wanda is the
scarlet witch is even though she's
probably being possessed and a little
bit controlled she's gonna be on a
rampage to go and try and find her kids
it makes you wonder how it's going to
end because she's definitely not going
to be dying at the end of this movie
especially with all the recent rumors
and talk about her possibly getting her
own movie eventually down the road but
let me know what you think let me know
how you think this is all going to end
in the comments down below don't forget
to give the video a like and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
[Music]